c'est un petit fruit rouge c'est bon
c'est évidemment un très bel équilibre
ou en bouche c'est j'aurais cru qu'ils
avaient moins de sucre dont celui
laissant la pâte à modeler c'est curieux
c'est super c'est très sucré
[Musique]
nous avons recensé près d'une
cinquantaine de vins des alcoolisées
rouges blancs et rosés vendus en
épicerie ou à l' échec
on a réussi à trouver vraiment l'
équilibre avec un peu de talent vers sa
source
ça sent plus le jus wesh c est ça sent
pas bon
mines et attrayant ça sent les fruits
clairement il y a des gens qui ont
commencé à se consacrer à son
élaboration avec beaucoup plus de
sérieux nadia fournier a goûté à plus de
40 de ses 20 jusqu'en 2017
en fait tout comme vraiment des beaux
progrès dans la qualité générale des
vins existe aujourd'hui c'est un marché
en pleine expansion
fini le temps où on voulait seulement
dépanner les femmes enceintes alors
c'est plus seulement une catégorie de
remplacement pour un revers quand vous
êtes vous quand vous avez déjà trop
fêter ou un vacances est reconduite ans
est en train de s'établir comme une
catégorie à une alternative
le fait que des maisons comme freixenet
s'intéresse aux vins d actualiser sa
indique que c'est une catégorie qui
suscite de plus en plus l'intérêt des
consommateurs et qui est considérée
probablement de façon sérieuse d'un
point de vue économique
signe que le consommateur est là et que
les grands joueurs ne peuvent plus
ignorer cette tendance d'une plus grande
sobriété ou en tout cas cette volonté de
diminution de consommation d'alcool
la complémentarité exa nous avons évité
isabelle une consommatrice et giampaolo
un directeur de restauration à se
joindre à une dégustation à l'aveuglé de
10/20 choisi par nadia je veux pas boire
tout le temps là c'est sûr que ça c'est
parfait pour moi de savoir s'il ya des
possibilités dans le vin des accusés
d'avoir des choix qui sont autres que
alcoolisées pour père et avec un repas
je pense que c'est une bonne idée
merci d'invitation qui a
pour débuter 80 blanc des alcoolisées ce
sont des vins qui pourrait plaire à des
consommateurs des amateurs de vin blanc
dans tous les profils de goût sa part
les pêches les nectarines quelque chose
comme ça avec ce n'est là je m'attends à
ce que ça soit sucré c'est très légitime
ça coûte beaucoup joué déjà vous voyez
des différences on est l'odeur c'est
très dur à décrire c'est quand même un
jour de monsieur un poème j'ai peut-être
eu jeu comme si je vivais dans un truc
carteirac automne on parle de vin sans
alcool mais ce sont en réalité des 20
désanm colisée au moyen de différentes
méthodes ans se sont évadés alcoolisées
parce que d'abord pour avoir droit à
l'appellation vin il faut qu'il y ait eu
un processus de fermentation donc un
dégagement d'alcool soit ça me plaît
plus plus d'acidité
je trouve que c'est très très floral
c'est donc c'est vraiment le nez qui
vous rappelle sa et en bouche est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est aussi sucré mais
c'est sa goutte à goutte de jus de pomme
a fait pas mal ce crime moi c'est
jusqu'à présent c'est vraiment de loin
mon favori c'est celui je trouve aussi
qui ressemble le plus à un vin bref je
le bois de la halle mètres sur une carte
de surprise surprise
je sais pas peut-être oui oui sûrement
ça c'est quelque chose qui me semble que
je me maintenir dans un coup de miel à
une saga de paul viel com le troisième
ça rappelle plus un vain mais je laime -
d'enlever ce qui est grave c'est en
rodage en bouche repose sur le glycérol
et c'est principalement ce que l'on perd
quand on des alcooliques et compense en
ajoutant du sucre du mou ou du jus de
raisin
c'est ce qui donne en moyenne une teneur
en sucre 5 fois plus élevé que dans du
vin ordinaire autour des roses et
maintenant c'est surprenant
j'aime bien le côté des blancs c'est
bizarre ça goûte la barre oui c'est
peut-être possible en fait que didier à
s'étirer ça se produit lors des
transformations malolactique donc si une
transformation de l'acier de manicamp
menacé de lactique ya potentiellement
des arômes de bars à boké fruits vins
bord de piscine 22 l'oeil finalement les
quatre rouges
le fait que ce soit rouge et qui a des
tanins ça apporte un degré
supplémentaire de complexité pour la
dégustation donc regarder centaine çà çà
çà çà sent quelque chose de sale et le
truc liberté en bouche c'est c'est
vraiment velouté un peu sucré je suis
très d'accord le nez très différents
une embauche c'est pas mauvais mais je
l'achèterai pas le deuxième c'est drôle
mais ça coûte les figues
mais comme les figues séchées et il est
probable un deuxième qui qui qui
réconcilie mots m'ont et ma bouche
en venant ici aujourd'hui je m'attendais
pas à dire d'un vin sans alcool qu'il
avait une certaine longueur mais ça va
reste en bouche donc ça puis denis bon
point l'équilibré vraiment réussi il
sait pas trop sucré c'est et ça goûte
pleuvait des bhoutanais honnêtement
c'est intéressant je surpris les vins
sans alcool se détaillent entre 5 et 17
dollars une fourchette de prix qui
s'explique si c'est trop cher on est en
train de me dire que ce sera pas un
produit de qualité alors soit on veut
que les gens aient envie de le bois il
faut qu'ils nous croient que cette
qualité il faut que le prix indique ce
en même temps on pourra australasie prix
aussi élevés que les plus grands
vraiment bien qu'il y ait place à
amélioration sur la quarantaine des vins
désorganisé déguster 5 se sont démarqués
les blancs bonne nouvelle et naturéo les
rosés original et carl jung
ainsi que le rouge bon voyage et ils
sont tous sous la barre des 10 dollars
et dernier conseil les vins sans alcool
ne sont pas des vins de garde
on n'a pas d'intérêt à faire vieillir cv
l'a donc la fraîcheur et la clé d'autant
plus que pour ces pages comme le muscat
on veut vraiment maximiser la fraîcheur
des arts où ils vont se dégrader avec le
temps